This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《少走弯路》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯。这个节目探讨黑人男性的经历，进行一些在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个懂行的持证专业人士一起交流。有多少男人带着一套铠甲。它向世界传递出一个信号，即你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，去听听。
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
《少走弯路》，在IHeart广播应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听。2%。这是当旁边有自动扶梯时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在奇特现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建设复原力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你会以一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
更充实、更健康的自己的面貌出现在世人面前。收听《2%》。即数字2和%，在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的惩罚。我们常说，相信你的女朋友们。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
听听女朋友们的意见。相信我，宝贝，在IHeart广播应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回首往事》（Look Back at it）播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重大时刻。1984对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course,
和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈80年代。1984年是一个疯狂的年份。那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《回首往事》。大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十岁时经历的最大变化、时刻和过渡期，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能回来收听新的一集，当然我们要，
break down the psychology of your 20s. Today, let's talk about change. Let's talk about transitional periods. Let's talk about growth, progress, like the huge shifts that we experience in our 20s. These moments that are on like the precipice of something new feel very exciting. They feel very romantic. They feel very thrilling. But let's be honest, change is one of those things that I think sounds super fun in theory,
剖析你二十岁的心理。今天，我们来聊聊改变。聊聊过渡期。聊聊成长、进步，比如我们在二十岁时经历的巨大转变。那些处于某种新事物边缘的时刻感觉非常令人兴奋。它们感觉非常浪漫。它们感觉非常惊心动魄。但老实说，我觉得改变在理论上听起来超级有趣，
but is sometimes absolutely horrible and painful in practice. In fact, at times, I think it really sucks. And it has us really wishing that we'd stayed the same. We all have ambitions for kind of like the ways we like to change our lives or like to live our lives. We want a new job. We want to move to a new city. We want better friendships. Whatever it is that's currently on your goal list, it's funny that often the second like a real
但在实践中有时却绝对糟糕且痛苦。事实上，有时我真觉得这太糟糕了。这让我们无比渴望自己从未改变过。我们所有人对于自己想要改变生活或生活方式的途径都有着各种野心。我们想要一份新工作。我们想要搬到一个新城市。我们想要更好的友谊。无论你的目标清单上目前有什么，有趣的是，通常只要一有真正
opportunity to enact that occurs or to make change happen appears we shrink and we find a lot of reasons not to do it we don't feel prepared we suddenly find ourselves sabotaging our habits and our momentum we convince ourselves we can't right when we're actually about to I was actually speaking to a friend about this the other day who has like this terrible horrible job like downright workplace bullying situation. She's ready to get out. She's ready to leave. But she's been working on her resume. And I'm saying this with love. She knows I'm sharing this. But she's been working on her resume for three months now and hasn't applied for a single job yet. And I said to her, you know, I asked her, I was like, live, like you've just got to apply, even if it's just for
实施该计划或促成改变的机会出现时，我们就会退缩，并找出大量不这样做的理由。我们觉得自己没有准备好，突然发现自己在破坏自己的习惯和势头。就在我们真正即将采取行动的时候，我们说服自己办不到。其实我前几天还在和一个朋友谈论这件事，她有一份非常糟糕的工作，简直就是职场霸凌。她准备不干了。她准备离开。但她一直在修改简历。我是带着善意说这番话的。她知道我会分享这个。但她改简历已经改了三个月了，却连一份工作都还没申请。我对她说，你知道的，我问她，我说，丽夫，你必须去申请，哪怕只是为了
practice. Why aren't you just applying even if you know you're going to get rejected? And she was like, well, what if I actually get the job? What if I get the job? What if I get the job? and I'm not ready and my whole life changes and I'm not prepared yet. This is what we're talking about. This inertia, this fear. Why does this happen? Why do we resist change, especially in our 20s when we should, supposedly, according to what everyone around us and older than us is saying,
练习。为什么不直接申请呢，哪怕你知道自己会被拒绝？她却说，嗯，如果我真的被录取了怎么办？如果我拿到这份工作怎么办？如果我拿到这份工作怎么办？而我还没准备好，我整个人生都变了，我还没准备好。这就是我们在讨论的。这种惰性，这种恐惧。为什么会这样？为什么我们要抗拒改变，尤其是在我们二十岁的时候？按照身边的长辈所说，
when we should have all the nerve and all the goals in the world? In this episode, I want to unpack the very deep psychology behind this paradox, the paradox of wanting to grow, but equally clinging to what is the same. Does this say something about our character? Is it a personal flaw? Is it a human instinct? Is it anxiety? Is it something else entirely?
本该拥有这世上所有的勇气和目标的时候？在这一集中，我想剖析这种悖论背后的深层心理学，即渴望成长却又同样死守现状的悖论。这说明了我们的性格吗？这是一个个人缺陷吗？这是一个人类本能吗？是焦虑吗？还是完全是别的东西？
I'm going to give you some of the answers. We'll look at why this specifically feels so scary in our 20s, why we're so afraid of losing what we already have, and what we might actually be quietly losing, and how we might actually be losing more scientifically, mathematically, psychologically, by choosing the same old, by staying the same. I've learned in my 20 so far that some of the very best decisions are also the ones that terrify us the most.
我将给你一些答案。我们将探讨为什么在二十岁时这种感觉尤为可怕，为什么我们如此害怕失去已经拥有的东西，以及我们实际上可能在悄悄失去什么，以及通过选择一成不变、保持现状，我们在科学、数学、心理学上究竟可能失去更多。我在二十岁时学到的一点是，一些最好的决定往往也是最让我们感到恐惧的决定。
So I want to interrogate that a little bit further and hopefully convince you as well. Without further ado, let's get into it. So to kind of start us off, let's look at what it is about changing. change that feels so scary, especially in our 20s. Firstly, I think change feels particularly stressful during this decade because we're just surrounded by so much of it, right? We're kind of drowning in it. We never get a break from it.
所以我希望对此作进一步的探讨，并希望能说服你们。闲话少说，我们切入正题吧。那么，为了开启这个话题，让我们来看看究竟是什么让改变，尤其是二十岁时的改变，显得如此可怕。首先，我认为在这个十年里，改变会带来特别大的压力，因为我们周围充斥着太多的改变，对吧？我们几乎被它淹没了。我们从不曾从中获得片刻喘息，
So it's hard to not fear more of it, especially the kind that could be randomly thrust on you at any given moment. A really relevant theory that comes up time and time again on the podcast is on its concept of emerging adulthood, which spans basically the late teens through the, through to the end of our 20s. Typically, if I was to ask you, you know, what are the developmental life stages of being a human? You would probably say childhood, teen years, adulthood, late adulthood. But emerging adulthood points to this distinct life stage of like almost adulthood, where everything is kind of in between. You know, you're no longer a teen. You're not a
所以很难不对此感到恐惧，尤其是那种可能在任何特定时刻随机强加给你的改变。在播客中屡次出现的一个非常相关的理论是关于成年初期（emerging adulthood）的概念，它基本上涵盖了从青春期后期到二十岁结束的这段时间。通常，如果我问你，你知道的，人类发育的生命阶段有哪些？你可能会说童年、青少年时期、成年期、成年晚期。但成年初期指出了一个独特的生命阶段，即“准成年”，在这个阶段一切都处于过渡状态。你知道的，你不再是青少年了，
teenager, but you also don't feel like a settled version of yourself, especially not the kind of imagined as a child. You know, when I was a kid, I genuinely thought that I'd be married with my own kids by now. And what was I thinking? I don't even know who I am as a person yet. This period of emerging adulthood has a few key battles in store for us. Identity exploration, instability, feeling in between, loneliness and loss. it feels like because of all these battles we're facing, because of all these milestones were going through, every six months of my 20s at least, I'm like an entirely new person. Every six months I feel like I'm just completely reborn.
你不再是青少年，但你也不觉得自已是一个定型的自己，尤其不是那种小时候想象的自己。你知道的，当我还是个孩子的时候，我真心以为自己到这个年纪已经结婚并有了自己的孩子。我当时在想什么？我甚至还不知道自己作为一个独立的人究竟是谁。这段成年初期的时期为我们准备了几场关键的战役。身份探索、不稳定感、夹在中间的感觉、孤独与失落。感觉由于我们面临的所有这些战役，由于我们正在经历的所有这些里程碑，在我二十岁的每个六个月里，至少有那么一段时间，我完全变成了另一个人。每隔六个月，我都觉得自己仿佛完全获得了重生。
Like Gemma in early 2025 versus now, I honestly think that me and her would struggle to even have a conversation. Just for example, for you, think back over the last year of your life. there are parts of yourself from only 12 months ago that you probably can't relate to anymore because of how rapidly our lives change during this distinct period of life. The emotional and the psychological environment this creates means that when another big change comes along, even a positive one, you don't necessarily experience it as a fun thing or a fun little upgrade. The first thing I know my mind goes to,
比如2025年初的杰玛与现在的杰玛相比，我老实说，我和她甚至很难进行一场对话。举个例子，回想一下你过去一年的生活。你可能已经无法与仅仅12个月前的自己产生共鸣了，因为在这个独特的生命时期，我们的生活变化得太快了。这种情绪和心理环境意味着，当另一个重大改变到来时，哪怕是一个积极的改变，你也不一定会把它当作一件有趣的事或小小的升级来体验。我脑海中浮现的第一件事是，
when change is happening in my life? Even good change is like, how the hell am I going to fit this in? How am I going to adapt to this? Am I ready for this? Do I have the space? It's something that like my mom always said to me, which is that even good stress is still stress. There's an element of cognitive overload going on.
当生活发生变化时？即使是好的改变，也会想：我到底该怎么把这塞进行程里？我该如何适应这个？我准备好了吗？我有这个空间吗？正如我妈妈经常对我说的那样，即使是好的压力也依然是压力。这里存在着某种认知超载的成分。
We're balancing so much involuntarily that sometimes it's hard to get excited or motivated by the change we choose because we just don't have the energy. That's the 20s explanation. That's why we specifically often, you know, fall away from change during this decade and under these circumstances. Here is the more human explanation. Simply put, we as humans are wired from our amygdala to our frontal lobe to prefer coherence, to prefer a sense that our life story makes sense, that we know kind of roughly where we are going, roughly where we've been, roughly where we are now. This, you know, a very rudimentary sense of stability is really important for maintaining homeostasis,
我们无意中平衡了太多的事情，以至于有时很难对我们选择的改变感到兴奋或有动力，因为我们根本没有精力。这就是二十岁的解释。这就是为什么我们经常在这个十年里、在这种情况下远离改变。以下是更具人性的解释。简单来说，从杏仁核到额叶，人类的生理机制就是倾向于连贯性，倾向于让我们的生活轨迹讲得通，让我们大致知道自己要去哪里，大致知道自己去过哪里，大致知道自己现在在哪里。这种，
the natural equilibrium of our systems that allows us to function because we feel safe enough. Something that I heard recently is like your brain doesn't care if you're growing, your brain doesn't care if you're fulfilled. It literally only cares that you are safe. I'm not going to bore you guys with the evolutionary perspective because I think we all know it by now. But anything unknown, anything unknown that change brings signals danger, triggering a whole set of stressed-based reactions that are meant to shock your body into action. These reactions also exhausts to your body. And so our very smart systems learn to anticipate things that are going to cause this much of a shake-up and to be fearful of them, to be fearful of change.
一种非常基础的稳定感对于维持稳态（homeostasis）至关重要，稳态是我们生理系统的自然平衡，它能让我们正常运转，因为我们感到了足够的安全。我最近听到的一句话是，你的大脑才不在乎你是否在成长，你的大脑才不在乎你是否感到满足。它真正在乎的只有你是否安全。我不会用进化论的观点来烦你们，因为我想大家现在都已经很清楚了。但任何未知的事物，改变带来的任何未知事物，都在向我们发出危险的信号，从而引发一整套旨在通过惊吓让你的身体采取行动的压力反应。这些反应也会耗尽你身体的体力。因此，我们非常聪明的系统学会了去预测那些会引起如此巨大震荡的事情，并对它们感到恐惧，对改变感到恐惧。
In contrast, the known, obviously, signal safety and therefore the peaceful and calm conditions our body needs to function properly. We are of course going to lean more towards that second state, more towards known peace, stability, safety, even if that means not really pushing ourselves. The thing is, our body's dedication to this homeostasis often works against us because it asks us to automatically resist new things, even if those things are good for us. Your mind is in many ways hardwired to want you to stay the same. It doesn't want to expend energy for no good reason. It's really happy how it is because it knows what's going on. They have done study after study on this. Your body, as soon as you ask it to change, is going to dig its heels in. That is why weight loss
相比之下，已知的事物显然预示着安全，因此也预示着我们的身体正常运转所需的平和与平静条件。我们当然会更倾向于第二种状态，更倾向于已知的平和、稳定、安全，即使这意味着我们不再真正逼迫自己。问题在于，身体对这种稳态的执着往往与我们作对，因为它要求我们自动抗拒新事物，哪怕这些事物对我们有益。在许多方面，你的大脑天生就想让你保持不变。它不想无缘无故地消耗能量。它对现状非常满意，因为它知道发生了什么。人们对此进行过一项又一项的研究。一旦你要求身体做出改变，它就会死守阵地。这就是为什么减肥
is so hard. That is why quitting substances is so hard. That is why undoing relationship patterns is so hard. Your brain is like a bike with broken handlebars that keeps steering you back in the direction. You don't want to go. You have to keep forcibly moving it back onto the path that you've chosen. It does this, yes, through literal biological resistance, but mainly by influencing our appraisal of any and all new situations so that we expect the worst. In behavioral economics, Daniel Carmen and Amos Tversky developed something called the Prospect Theory. They developed this back in the 1970s and they essentially showed that humans do not evaluate gains and losses in a balanced way. We typically want to avoid loss as much as possible.
如此艰难。这就是为什么戒除瘾品如此艰难。这就是为什么打破恋爱模式如此艰难。你的大脑就像一辆车把手坏了的自行车，一直把你往相反的方向推。你不得不强行把它搬回你所选择的道路上。它这样做，是的，通过字面上的生物学抵抗，但主要是通过影响我们对所有新情况的评估，让我们总是预期最坏的结果。在行为经济学中，丹尼尔·卡尼曼和阿莫斯·特沃斯基提出了所谓的“前景理论”。他们在20世纪70年代提出了这个理论，他们基本上表明，人类对收益和损失的评估并不是平衡的。我们通常希望尽可能地避免损失。
So our focus is disproportionately on what kind of losses change is going to bring us. There is a larger assessment of those things that are scary and that we could lose versus what we have to gain, even if the losses and gains are equal, even if we actually have more to gain. Irrationally, our brain still keeps going back to what we have to lose. For example, I'll give you some research that backs this up. Research has shown that in an experimental condition where people are given 50 tokens to begin and they either gain 10 additional tokens or have 10 tokens randomly taken away,
因此，我们的注意力不成比例地集中在改变会给我们带来什么样的损失上。我们会对那些可怕的、我们可能会失去的东西进行更多的评估，相比之下，我们能获得什么则被抛诸脑后，即便损失和收益是对等的，即便我们实际上有更多可赚取的。极其不理智的是，我们的大脑总是会回到我们可能会失去的东西上。例如，我举一些支持这一点的研究。研究表明，在实验条件下，人们一开始会得到50个代币，他们要么额外获得10个代币，要么随机被拿走10个代币，
later on when they're asked to estimate, you know, what proportion, what percentage do you think you lost or gained in this situation. The people who had 10 tokens taken away suggested they had lost almost 15% more than they actually had. Whereas those who had gained extras usually estimated it more accurately. They usually were like, yeah, around 10, around 5%, around 10%, whatever it was. These people weren't just bad at math, right? What it's really showing is that our brains, focus, expand, skew our perception of what we have to lose. This means that when we encounter situations of uncertainty and change, even good change, our anticipation for what may go wrong will often be so much greater than our excitement for the possibility of what will go right.
后来当被要求估计，你知道的，你认为在这个情况下你损失或获得的比例是多少时。那些被拿走10个代币的人认为他们损失的比例比实际情况多出近15%。而那些获得额外代币的人通常估计得更准确。他们通常会说，嗯，大概10个，大概5%，大概10%，无论具体数字是多少。这些人并不是不擅长数学，对吧？真正表明的是，我们的大脑，其注意力、放大作用、扭曲了我们对自己可能失去的东西的感知。这意味着，当我们遇到不确定性和改变的情况时，哪怕是好的改变，我们对可能出错的事情的预期，往往也会远远大于我们对可能变好的事情的兴奋感。
This contributes to what we know as the status quo bias. Basically, we'd rather stick with how things are. even if they're not amazing, because change feels too risky and too much of a burden. There's actually quite a famous paper from the 80s that explores this. It was published in the Journal of Risk and Uncertainty. And essentially, in a series of these decision-making experiments where participants were given a default option, they disproportionately stuck with that option, even when the alternatives were objectively better. They could win $20.
这就促成了我们所知的现状偏误（status quo bias）。基本上，我们宁愿维持现状。哪怕现状并不是好得不得了，因为改变感觉风险太大，负担太重。80年代其实有一篇非常著名的论文探讨了这一点。它发表在《风险与不确定性杂志》（Journal of Risk and Uncertainty）上。基本上，在一系列决策实验中，当参与者被赋予一个默认选项时，他们不成比例地坚守该选项，即使其他替代方案客观上更好。他们可以赢得20美元。
They could win prizes. They could also lose $10, but they actually went for neither of those things. They didn't want to win $20. They didn't want to lose $10. They just did nothing. They stuck with what they had. Now, if we apply this pattern of behavior to our actual lives, think about it. You might be in a job that's all right.
他们可以赢得奖品。他们也可能损失10美元，但他们实际上这两者都没选。他们不想赢20美元。他们也不想输10美元。他们什么也没做。他们坚守了自己已有的东西。现在，如果我们把这种行为模式应用到我们的现实生活中，想想看。你可能正处于一份还算可以的工作中。
It's okay. You know, it pays the rent. It pays for your car payment. You know, you sort of know, you sort of know, you're doing. You have colleagues you chat to, but deep down, you know you're not growing. You know a part of you feel stuck. And then another opportunity appears. It's a different role, maybe it's in a different city, maybe a different field. On paper, it's better. But your brain doesn't see stable job versus better job. Instead, it interprets this as loss of security,
还行吧。你知道的，它能付得起房租。它能支付你的车贷。你知道的，你大致知道，你大致清楚自己在做什么。你有可以聊天的同事，但内心深处，你知道自己没有在成长。你知道自己的一部分感到了困顿。然后另一个机会出现了。这是一个不同的角色，也许是在不同的城市，也许是不同的领域。纸面上来看，它更好。但你的大脑看到的不是“稳定工作”与“更好工作”的对比。相反，它将其解读为失去安全感，
loss of familiarity, loss of routine, loss of competence, and interesting job. It doesn't assess those two what there is to lose and what there is to gain accurately. You know those potential gains, more fulfillment, more alignment, more money, a more aligned path to our brain, to our present-day brain, they're kind of abstract, they're in the future. They're difficult to imagine because they're not in front of you, the way that the potential losses are, the way that they're very vivid because the thing you have to lose is right there. That again is also why change feels so unstable because the losses are always going to be more visual and apparent versus the gains that haven't happened yet.
失去熟悉感，失去常规，失去胜任力，以及失去一份有趣的工作。它并不能准确评估这两者之间究竟有什么可失、有什么可得。你知道那些潜在的收益——更多的成就感、更多的契合度、更多的金钱、一条更符合心意的道路——对于我们的大脑、对于我们现在的大脑来说，它们有点抽象，它们在未来。它们很难想象，因为它们并不在你眼前，不像潜在的损失那样生动，因为你必须失去的东西就在那里。这也是为什么改变会让人感到如此不稳定的原因，因为损失永远比那些尚未发生的收益更具视觉冲击力和显而易见。
I think it's the same dynamic in relationships as well. Leaving a relationship that isn't working or isn't quite fulfilling means potentially losing a companionship that you already understand and a history that you understand, because you were there and the in-laws that you've grown to like because you see them all the time. The idea that, you know, leaving that person might mean you gain self-respect. Might mean you gain inner peace. Might mean that you gain a compatible partner, a more compatible partner later on. That's really intangible because you haven't met them yet.
我认为恋爱关系中也是同样的动态。离开一段行不通的或无法给予足够满足感的关系，意味着可能会失去一段你已经习惯了的陪伴，以及你所了解的历史，因为你曾身处其中，还有那些你因为经常见面而逐渐喜欢上的亲家。那种认为，你知道的，离开这个人可能意味着你重新获得了自尊。可能意味着你获得了内心的平静。可能意味着你以后会找到一个更合拍的伴侣、一个更合适的伴侣。这些都是非常虚无缥缈的，因为你还没遇到他们呢。
You can't feel it. So it's not as emotionally weighted in the same way, even if you know in your heart of hearts that this is, probably, if not absolutely 100%, the right decision. We can understand this a little bit further through something called terror management theory. Sounds very extreme, but it's basically a social psychology framework that suggests that suggests that a lot of our need for security, for routine, for self-esteem is connected to the fact that we're aware that on some level, life is very fragile and life. is finite. Change, especially the big, irreversible kind, brushes up a lot of existential fears. Brushes up against this idea that we might not be in control, that things can go wrong, that we can make mistakes, that we only have limited time here so we better make the right decisions.
你感觉不到它。因此它的情感分量不一样，即使你内心深处知道这很可能是正确的决定，即使不是绝对百分之百。我们可以通过所谓的恐怖管理理论更进一步地理解这一点。听起来很极端，但它基本上是一个社会心理学框架，表明我们的许多安全感、常规需求、自尊需求都与一个事实有关：我们在某种程度上意识到生命是非常脆弱的，生命是有限的。改变，尤其是那种重大的、不可逆转的改变，会激发出很多对生存的恐惧。它会触及这样一种观念：我们可能无法掌控一切，事情可能会出差错，我们会犯错，我们在这里的时间有限，所以我们最好做出正确的决定。
Our desire to keep returning to what we know is partly about managing our anxiety, about our own fragility. So when you're clinging to a situation that is fine, that is okay, you know, not great job, all right partner, city that feels kind of restrictive. You might be like, why do I keep doing this? Why can't I move on? And it's because your brain is trying to protect you from a very real sense of loss and of uncertainty. And on a deeper level, this sense that actually nothing is guaranteed. Maybe I can't make it work in this new location, this new relationship, this new life. Your resistance to change is therefore. very natural. It's being influenced by a lot of, I would say, very powerful, very complex processes.
我们不断回归自己所熟悉的事物的欲望，部分是为了管理我们对自身脆弱性的焦虑。因此，当你执着于一段还算过得去的现状时，比如工作其实不怎么好、伴侣马马虎虎、所在的城市感觉有点束缚。你可能会想：我为什么一直在这样做？为什么我无法向前迈进？那是因为你的大脑正试图保护你免受一种非常真实的失落感和不确定感的影响。在更深层次上，这种感觉其实是没有任何事情是有保障的。也许我无法在新地点、新关系、新生活中取得成功。因此，你对改变的抗拒是非常自然的。它受到了许多我可以说非常强大、非常复杂的过程的影响。
To be honest, when I look at all these things lined up, I'm surprised anybody ever takes a risk ever. Like if that's what we're battling against, like existential fears, a hardwired fear of the unknown, like neurological patterns that don't want to break, I can't, I, it's pretty courageous that people ever do anything. But the thing is, and this is the point I think we all realize eventually, we don't only lose things when we change. We also lose things when we stay the same. Staying the same also has a cost. When you don't apply for the role you're really drawn to, someone else gets it. Someone else gets the mentoring and the skills and the money. Someone else who may have less skills than you gets that opportunity just because they have the bravado. When you don't move to the new
说实话，当我看着所有这些事情摆在面前时，我惊讶于居然有人敢去冒险。就像如果我们正在对抗的是这些——生存的恐惧、对未知的本能恐惧、不想打破的神经模式——我觉得人们能做任何事都相当勇敢。但问题是，这也是我们最终都会意识到的一点：我们在改变时不仅会失去东西。我们在原地踏步时也会失去东西。保持不变也是有代价的。当你没有去申请你真正心仪的职位时，别人得到了它。别人得到了指导、技能和金钱。另一个可能不如你熟练的人仅仅因为有勇气就得到了那个机会。当你没有搬到那个
city that you're that you're daydreaming about, there's a person in that new city who would have been your best friend. You never get to meet them. That relationship never happens. There's memories that are never made. Fond memories, memories that you would have had till the day you die. You weren't there to make them. You know, when you don't leave, the relationship you know is wrong for you. You're also blocking the space for a more compatible partner or maybe just simply a more peaceful relationship with yourself. This, all these examples are what is known as opportunity cost. It's a term from economics that's actually super replicable here.
你一直在幻想的城市时，在那个新城市里有一个本可以成为你最好朋友的人。你永远无法遇见他们。那种关系永远不会发生。有些记忆永远不会被创造。美好的回忆，那些你本可以陪伴到生命尽头的回忆。你不在那里创造它们。你知道的，当你没有离开那段你深知不适合你的关系时。你也挡住了空间，无法迎接一个更契合的伴侣，或者也许只是无法与自己建立一种更平和的关系。所有这些例子就是所谓的“机会成本”。这是一个经济学概念，在这里其实非常适用。
You guys know, I never miss a moment to tell you guys. I actually also have an economics degree. I have to do my humble brag every time it comes up. But opportunity cost is one of the concepts you learn like on day one of microeconomics. And it's basically the value of the next best alternative. You give up when you choose something. and it's something that it costs you in a way in the ways of disappointment, regret, but also in the ways that you could have taken all that energy
你们都知道，我从不错过任何机会告诉大家。其实我也有经济学学位。每当提起这个我都要小小地自吹自擂一下。但机会成本是你在微观经济学第一天就学到的概念之一。它基本上就是当你选择某事时放弃的下一个最好替代方案的价值。这是你在某种程度上付出的代价，表现为失望、后悔，但也表现为你本可以把所有这些精力
and spent it on something that may have turned out better. And that's a cost that you have to bear by choosing. Every choice you make is also a set of choices you don't make. And not making a choice is the most costly of all of those choices. Every year you put off going back to university is a year you're not getting any closer to graduating. every month you put off starting that new exercise routine is another month that you just don't feel good about yourself. You don't feel 100% in your body. And those missed opportunities, they compound the way investments, you know, compound and get more expensive as well.
花在可能结果更好的事情上。这是你做出选择必须承担的代价。你所做的每一个选择，也是你没有做的一系列选择。而不做选择是所有这些选择中代价最高昂的。你每年推迟重返大学，就是你离毕业更远的一年；你每个月推迟开始新的锻炼习惯，就是你对自己的感觉不好的又一个月。你在身体上感觉不到百分之百的状态。而那些错过的机会，它们会像投资那样复利累积，你知道的，复利累积也会变得越来越昂贵。
You know how I always think about it? I always think about it when I'm doubting or thinking, do I do this thing or not. I always think about the people who bought a house like back in the 90s. And like that running joke of like if only I had 20,000, back in the 90s, I could be able to afford a house. And every year, houses just get more and more expensive. Investing in skills, investing in change right now is like buying a house in the 90s. Because in 30 years time, 40 years time, you're going to have this whole life that's been
你知道我是怎么想的吗？每当我怀疑或在想要不要做这件事时，我总是这样想。我总是想起那些在90年代买房的人。就像那个老笑话说的：如果我在90年代有2万块钱，我就能买得起房子了。每年，房子都变得越来越贵。投资技能，现在就投资改变，就像在90年代买房一样。因为在30年、40年后，你将拥有整个人生，它都是
built upon an investment you made back then that is compounded and compounded and compounded. Otherwise, if you don't do it, yeah, you don't have the house. You also live with the knowledge that you could have. You could have been the proud owner of the home. You could have been the proud owner of a highly valued life if you've just taken the risk and embraced change. And this right here is the final cost of not pursuing change. It's the discomfort of self-bretail,
建立在你当年做出的那项投资之上的，那个投资不断复利、复利、再复利。否则，如果你不去做，是的，你没有房子。你也带着这种认知生活：你本可以拥有。你本可以成为一个高价值生活的自豪拥有者，如果你当初只是冒险去拥抱改变的话。这正是拒绝追求改变的最终代价。这是自我阉割的不适感，
of knowing on some level that, you know, you abandoned your own needs and values and a future version of you who now doesn't get to exist because of your resistance to things being different. The thing is as well, we resist change now because we think the opportunity might linger and might come up later. But over time, I think it does become harder to imagine future changes going any differently because right now, you resisting changes building a track record of staying, of just accepting that this is how your life is. Like that narrative of like, this is just what it is, this is just what it is, it gets stronger and stronger. every day you allow it to continue to exist and not challenge it.
在某种程度上你知道，你放弃了自己的需求和价值观，而那个因为你抗拒事物发生变化而无法存在的未来版本的你。问题还在于，我们现在抗拒改变，是因为我们认为机会可能会逗留，以后可能会出现。但随着时间推移，我认为确实更难想象未来的改变会有所不同，因为现在你抗拒改变正在建立一种停留的记录，只是接受这就是你的生活。就像那种叙事：“生活就是这样，生活就是这样”，它一天天变得越来越强，只要你允许它继续存在而不去挑战它。
And I'm not saying you can't eventually change or that you won't or that there aren't choices out there that you will eventually take. But the thing is, some of the best decisions that we make in our lives are the ones that we don't feel prepared for because you can never be 100% certain that what you're going to do, the risk you're going to take is going to work out. How do we get over that mental barrier, the not knowing, the uncertainty? we're going to dive into exactly how some steps to embrace change after this short break.
我并不是说你最终不能改变，或者你不会改变，或者外面没有你最终会接受的选择。但问题是，我们在生活中做出的一些最好的决定，是我们感觉没有准备好的决定，因为你永远无法百分之百确定你要做的事、你要冒的险会有好结果。我们如何克服那个心理障碍，那个未知、不确定性？在这段简短的广告之后，我们将深入探讨如何采取具体步骤来拥抱改变。
So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and health. fitness experts and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
所以请继续收听。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了精神坚韧、体能以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康、健身专家等进行对话，看穿主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent. That's TW.0. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either.
我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是TWO percent。也就是TW.0。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands.
我们总是说要相信你的好姐妹。我是安娜·西恩菲尔德，在这个新季的《好姐妹》中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们约会的竟然是同一个多产的世纪骗子。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。所以她们决定自己动手。
I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. You remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的。收听《好姐妹》。相信我，宝贝。在Iheart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill,
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集有马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，
waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84's big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day but just so y'all know I mean at this point Mark this is the second episode where we've discussed crack so I'm starting to see
大谈80年代的可卡因。要明确的是，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊可卡因，但为了让大家知道，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集，所以我开始看出
there's a through line We also have AIDS on the table right now So Thank you finishing that sentence I don't think there's a more important year for black people Really?
我们有一条贯穿始终的主线。现在艾滋病也在桌面上，所以谢谢你完成那句话。我认为没有比这更重要的一年了，对黑人来说。真的吗？
Yeah for me It's one of the most important years For black people In American history Listen to look back at it On the IHeart Radio app Apple Podcasts Or wherever you get your podcasts
是的，对我来说，这是黑人历史上最重要的年份之一。收听《回顾过去》，在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tript Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough.
欢迎收听我的新播客《硬核学习》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时当我们追求某事物时，我们太过于投入追逐中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了该事物。而我们还在追逐它。并且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
因为人们在盯着记分牌。生活变成了关于赢和输。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世上做一个好人很重要？你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两个不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learn the hard way and listen now. Here's a pattern that I've noticed.
我希望你真正地成为一个好人。和我基尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《硬核学习》中，就治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标进行真正的对话。打开你免费的IHeart Radio应用程序，搜索“learn the hard way”并立即收听。这里有一个我注意到的模式。
I often think the decisions that are the most life-altering are the ones that actually you don't feel calm at the time about making. I think they're the ones that challenge you the most. In my own life, that was like living my first long-term relationship. This person I thought I was going to be with forever. Or quitting my job, leaving the comfort of a paycheck to work for myself. moving cities to a place I didn't know anybody. None of those decisions were easy.
我经常认为，那些最能改变人生的决定，往往是你在做决定时实际上并不感到平静的决定。我认为它们是那些对你挑战最大的决定。在我自己的生活中，那就像是结束我的第一段长期恋感。这个我以为我会永远和她在一起的人。或者辞掉工作，离开薪水的安稳去为自己工作。搬到我谁也不认识的城市。这些决定没有一个容易。
I actually put them all off much longer than I needed to. I was in that relationship, like, for six months longer than I should have been. Same with the job. It took two years for me to move to London. I still don't feel 100% certain about that decision sometimes. This is because a lot of big decisions have what we call approach avoidance conflicts. We've talked a lot about. losses and gains, as if a decision is either going to create all loss or all gain. The theory,
我实际上把它们都拖延了比我需要的时间长得多。我在那段感情里，多呆了大概六个月。工作也是如此。我花了两年时间才搬到伦敦。有时我对那个决定仍然没有百分之百的把握。这是因为很多重大决定都有我们所谓的趋避冲突。我们讨论了很多关于损失和收益的话题，就好像一个决定要么会带来全部损失，要么会带来全部收益。理论上，
this theory, though, says it's probably going to be a mix, undesirable and desirable things. Hopefully the desirable things went out, we don't always know. But what this means is that the closer we get to making a decision or a goal, the greater our anxiety, but also the greater our excitement, the feelings, those feelings, excitement anxiety, excitement anxiety, fear, anxiety, excitement, they can be indistinguishable at times. So we just basically end up being overwhelmed. This spike of anxiety that you receive where you feel is you near a decision point is incredibly normal because you're responding to essentially an increasing reality that things are going to change and that you're going to have to adapt. Not a possibility anymore, a reality.
然而这个理论表明，它可能是一个混合体，既有不可取的事物，也有可取的事物。希望可取的事物能胜出，我们并不总是知道。但这意味着，我们越接近做出决定或达成目标，我们的焦虑就越大，但兴奋感也越大，那些感觉——兴奋焦虑、兴奋焦虑、恐惧焦虑、兴奋焦虑——有时是无法区分的。所以我们最终基本上被压垮了。当你接近决策点时感受到的这种焦虑激增是极其正常的，因为你本质上是在回应一个不断增强的现实：事情将要改变，你将不得不适应。不再是一种可能性，而是一个现实。
I often think, you know, the more fear, the more pros and cons lists that you may the more you probably should go through with it, the more you probably should do it scared. Because when you're scared, it points to the fact that this possibility and what is being offered to you or what you think could come from this strikes a real nerve. It strikes a nerve deeply with what you value. If you didn't care, if you didn't fear this as much, if you weren't as overwhelmed by the choice, I feel like you wouldn't secretly kind of know that this is. what you need to do. I don't think you'd be having such a profound emotional reaction if this
我经常认为，你感受到的恐惧越多，你列出的利弊清单越多，你就越应该坚持下去，你就越应该带着恐惧去做这件事。因为当你感到害怕时，它指向了这样一种事实：这种可能性以及呈现在你面前的东西、或者你认为会从中得到的东西，真正触及了你的痛处。它深深地触及了你所珍视的东西。如果你不在乎，如果你对这种恐惧没有那么深，如果你没有被这个选择压得喘不过气来，我觉得你就不会暗暗知道这就是你需要做的事。我不认为你会产生如此深刻的情感反应，如果这个
thing wasn't right for you because you wouldn't be meaningfully invested enough to feel this way. What you're experiencing as anxiety and fear about change is your nervous system reacting to the magnitude of possibility and the unknowing, how unknown it is. And often we think that's just anxiety, a large part of it is anticipation, knowing that this has to be our reality, knowing it's only a matter of time until we take the plunge, knowing that things are going to be incredible. Don't let, you know, fear convince you that anticipation and excitement are the same as anxiety and that they're a bad thing and that they alone indicate that something is a bad decision. Your emotions don't know anything more than you do.
事情对你来说不是正确的，因为你没有投入足够的意义去产生这种感觉。你所经历的关于改变的焦虑和恐惧，是你的神经系统对可能性的巨大程度以及未知性（它是多么未知）的反应。通常我们认为那只是焦虑，其中很大一部分其实是期待，知道这必须成为我们的现实，知道这只是我们纵身一跃之前的时间问题，知道事情将会变得不可思议。不要让恐惧说服你，让你以为期待和兴奋与焦虑是一回事，它们是件坏事，而且它们本身就表明某事是个糟糕的决定。你的情绪并不比你知道得更多。
They don't know. They come from you. They originate from you. How do they know? I think the decisions you feel most intensely about just to nail this home, those are the ones, your soul, your heart, whatever it is you think it is, whatever label you give it, there is some deep part of you that is most drawn to them for a reason. With that being said, how do we take the leap?
它们什么也不知道。它们来自你。它们起源于你。它们怎么会知道？我认为你感受最强烈、最深切的决定，为了强调这一点，就是那些决定——你的灵魂、你的心，无论你认为它是什么，无论你给它贴上什么标签——你的内心深处总有一部分出于某种原因最被它们吸引。话虽如此，我们该如何纵身一跃？
When do we know that we're ready? When do we know it's time to jump? If you've spent most of your life treating change as this big, scary, dramatic threat, you're probably not going to wake up one day and be like, cool, I suddenly love this, I'm ready to go. A more realistic goal is just to change the story you tell yourself about what change means or about how emotionally ready you are for it. One theory that can help here that I found is the early 2000s Broaden and Build theory from somebody called Barbara Fredrickson. Broaden build is fantastic and it essentially suggests that counteracting limiting emotions like fear, pessimism, hopelessness with more positive emotions like curiosity, interest and hope, widens our attentional focus and lets us see more possibilities.
我们什么时候才知道自己准备好了？什么时候才知道是时候放手一搏了？如果你大半生都把改变视为一种巨大、可怕、戏剧性的威胁，你大概不会有一天突然醒来，心想：太棒了，我突然喜欢上这个了，我已经准备好出发了。一个更切合实际的目标，只是去改变你对自己所讲述的关于改变意味着什么的故事，或者关于你对它在情感上准备得有多充分的故事。这里有一个对我有帮助的理论，那就是芭芭拉·弗雷德里克森（Barbara Fredrickson）在2000年代初期提出的“拓展与建构”理论。“拓展与建构”理论非常棒，它本质上表明，用好奇心、兴趣和希望等更积极的情绪去对冲恐惧、悲观、绝望等限制性情绪，会拓宽我们的注意力焦点，让我们看到更多的可能性。
When fear and anxiety narrow our focus to the threat or what we have to lose because that is what they're meant to do, curiosity and hope gently just let you see beyond that pinpoint or see beyond the worst case scenario. Let yourself feel that first wave of like, this is going to go terrible, what am I doing? and then send in the second wave, send in the deliberate judgment, one of curiosity and excitement. For example, you might think I'm terrified to move, I'm terrified to start over, but also I'm slightly curious. I'm really excited for who I might become. You might think leaving this relationship is going to absolutely destroy me, my life is going to be over, but also I'm a tiny bit hopeful about the opportunities I'm going to have to meet new people on the other side.
当恐惧和焦虑将我们的焦点缩小到威胁或我们不得不失去的东西上时——因为这就是它们的作用所在——好奇心和希望会温柔地让你看到那个焦点之外的东西，或者看到最坏情况之外的东西。让自己感受到第一波浪潮，比如“这会糟透了，我在干什么？”，然后派上第二波浪潮，派上深思熟虑的判断，一种充满好奇心和兴奋的判断。例如，你可能会想：“我很害怕搬家，我很害怕重新开始，但我也有点好奇。我真的很兴奋，不知道自己会变成什么样的人。”你可能会想：“离开这段关系绝对会毁了我，我的生活要完蛋了，但对于另一边我将有机会结识新朋友，我也抱有一丝希望。”
Even better, if you want something super practical, you could do this literally right now, super practical. For every way you think that change, for every way you think this is going to go wrong, for every bad thing you think change is going to bring into your life, write a list of the five ways it could go right, or the five reasons that you'll be okay even if it doesn't. literally counteract it as much as you physically can with an overwhelming kind of wall of optimism
更好的是，如果你想要一些超级实用的方法，你现在就可以这么做，超级实用。对于你认为改变会带来的每一种可能出错的方式，对于你认为改变会给你的生活带来的每一种不好的事情，列出一张清单，写出它可能变好的五种方式，或者即使没有变好你也能够安然度过的五个理由。从物理上尽你所能，用排山倒海般的乐观主义、积极性以及可能性去对冲它。
and positivity and just possibility as well. You know why I love this tip? I love this tip because it proves that you can overthink the good stuff as well. You can overthink the positives as much as you can overthink the negatives. Another tip on top of this that I also swear by is when I am at like the precipice of a change and I'm like, oh my God, should I do this? Should I not do this? I just imagine telling the story of this very moment where I make the decision in five or ten years time. And I imagine telling it as a success story.
你知道我为什么喜欢这个建议吗？我喜欢这个建议，因为它证明了你对美好的事物也可以过度思考。你可以像过度思考消极事情一样过度思考积极事情。除此之外，我还有一个深信不疑的建议，那就是当处于改变的悬崖边，心想“天哪，我该这么做吗？我不该这么做吗？”时，我只是想象在五到十年后讲述这个做出决定的当下时刻的故事。我把它想象成一个成功的故事。
I imagine it as me sitting around a dinner table being like, this was the beginning. This is where I, this was my origin story. This was the rise. This moment right here, the one I'm most afraid in is the one I'm going to come back to time and time again. There's a lot of research on post-traumatic growth and also on major life transitions that suggest that we cope better with upheaval, we cope better with things going wrong or with change, when we can place it into a story about what our lives are for and the purpose we are living and the journey we are taking. When you create a narrative about who you could be
我把它想象成自己坐在餐桌旁说：“这就是开始。这就是我，这就是我的起源故事。这就是崛起。”此时此刻，这个我最害怕的时刻，将是我一次又一次回溯的时刻。有很多关于创伤后成长以及重大生活转折的研究表明，当我们能够把动荡、事情出错或改变置于一个关于我们的生活是为了什么、我们正在过着什么目的以及我们正在踏上什么旅程的故事中时，我们就能更好地应对它们。当你创造一个关于你可能成为谁的叙事时……
as the result of what's happening to you right now, or what might be happening for you in the future, and you reframe that change as a process that is happening to you, for you, in your favor rather than against you, it suddenly feels like this is the most natural thing in the world. You have to do this. I also think, you know, if you want a good story, if you want a good origin story about your life,
……作为你此刻正在经历的事情的结果，或者作为未来可能为你发生的事情的结果，并将这种改变重新定义为一个正在向你发生、为了你发生、对你有利而不是对你不利的过程，它突然感觉就像是世界上最自然的事情。你必须这么做。我也觉得，如果你想要一个好故事，如果你想要一个关于你生活的精彩起源故事……
you've got to build it, you've got to make it, you've got to be courageous enough to take risks, and that's what you're doing right now. You're building the story and you're making it an interesting one by embracing change. I think if change is continuously framed as something that's just only pointless, only chaos, only emotional disruption, it will always feel like a negative. It will always feel like something to avoid. But if it's framed as the way you become more yourself, the way that you get to your goals, the path through,
……你必须构建它，你必须创造它，你必须有勇气去承担风险，而这正是你现在正在做的事情。你正在构建这个故事，并通过拥抱改变让它变得引人入胜。我认为，如果改变总是被框定为仅仅是毫无意义的、仅仅是混乱的、仅仅是情感上的破坏，它就永远会让人觉得是一种负面影响。它永远会让人觉得是需要逃避的事情。但如果它被框定为你变得更真实的途径、你实现目标的途径、度过难关的路径……
it starts to feel more like a transition, not just the end outcome. I think it helps to remember that change is also rarely one big cinematic leap. Instead, it's usually a series of small stages, small steps. Another model, I guess, theory that I love is the trans-theoretical model of change. This was developed by researchers in the 90s, and it describes change, as not a before and after, but moving through phases where occasionally things aren't working and occasionally they're working really well. You know, you move through these phases of like not really considering it yet, then seriously thinking about it, then preparing, then acting,
它开始更像是一种过渡，而不仅仅是最终结果。我认为这有助于记住，改变也很少是一次性的大飞跃。相反，它通常是一系列的小阶段、小步骤。另一个我喜爱的模型或理论是“跨理论改变模型”。这是由90年代的研究人员开发的，它将改变描述为不是非黑即白的“之前”与“之后”，而是在各个阶段中穿行，偶尔事情进展不顺利，偶尔进展得非常顺利。你知道，你会经历这些阶段：还没怎么认真考虑，然后开始认真考虑，接着是准备，然后是行动……
then trying to maintain the new behavior. The key thing is that people slide back and forth through these stages all the time. They're prepared, they're not prepared. They're sticking with that habit, suddenly the habit is broken. The thing is that they're always continuing to have forward motion even within the cycle. They're always trying to get back to the place they want to be. So if you've been thinking about moving city, if you've been thinking about leaving your job for whatever reason and you're still in that anticipation phase, the next stage is like only a few centimeters away. All you have to do is just shift yourself into that preparation stage, into that doing stage. Maybe you're not going to apply or keep applying or maybe you're not going to go through
……然后努力维持新的行为。关键在于，人们总是在这些阶段之间来回滑动。他们准备好了，又没准备好。他们坚持那个习惯，突然习惯又打破了。关键在于，即使在这个周期内，他们也总是在继续向前运动。他们总是在努力回到他们想去的地方。所以，如果你一直在考虑换城市，如果你由于某种原因一直在考虑辞职，而你仍处于那种期待阶段，那么下一个阶段离你只有几厘米远。你所要做的，就是把自己转入那个准备阶段，转入那个付诸行动的阶段。也许你不会去申请，或者不会继续申请，或者也许你不会坚持到底……
with it, but at least you can say you are in that stage even for a little while. Seeing changes as a process that has ambivalence, that has messiness, that has false starts and experimentation, like, all built into it, that is, that can soften the unise and it can soften the all or nothing thinking of like, if I'm going to accept, embrace, pursue change, I better be 100% committed or 100% not in at all. This links actually to a lot of the ideas that come from acceptance and commitment therapy. ACT, acceptance and commitment therapy, talks about committed action, which is basically taking concrete steps guided by your values to get what you want, not just things that are guided by your moment-to-moment emotions. Your values are telling you, I want to do this. This is the
但至少你可以说你处于那个阶段，哪怕只是一小会儿。将改变视为一个包含矛盾心理、混乱、草草收场和试验的过程——所有这些都内置其中——这可以软化这种不适感，并软化“如果我要接受、拥抱、追求改变，我最好100%投入，或者100%不参与”的非黑即白的思维。这实际上与接纳承诺疗法（ACT）中的许多想法联系在一起。ACT，即接纳承诺疗法，谈到了“承诺行动”，这基本上是指在价值观的指引下采取具体步骤来获得你想要的东西，而不仅仅是受当下情绪引导的事情。你的价值观在告诉你：“我想这么做。这是……”
necessary thing for me. I have to take the step if I want to be the kind of person I've envisioned. The fear is always going to be there. It just, you know, I'm just not going to let it dictate what I do. It's always going to be there. But let me ask you this. Take out the fear, take out the anxiety. What if I told you I knew for certainty every part of your plan was going to work out? I knew. Somebody had told me all the steps were going to be complete. Nothing was going to be go wrong. I could swear up and down that that was the case. All I needed from you was commitment. Commitment to the time it would take. If that was the situation, what outcome in those circumstances would you desire the most? What is the path you're going to pick if I said it was all going to work out?
……对我来说必要的事情。如果我想成为我所设想的那种人，我就必须采取这一步。恐惧总是会存在的。只是，你知道，我不会让它主导我的所作所为。它总是会存在的。但让我问你这个：抛开恐惧，抛开焦虑。如果我告诉你，我百分之百确定你的计划的每个部分都会成功呢？我知道。有人告诉我，所有的步骤都会完成。什么都不会出错。我敢打包票情况确实如此。我所需要你的，只是承诺。对它所需时间的承诺。如果是这种情况，在这种情况下你最渴望什么结果？如果我说一切都会顺利，你会选择什么路径？
That's what you want. It's as clear as day. Now, tell me why all the steps won't work out. Tell me why that's going to happen. Tell me why exactly you believe it's not going to go your way. You don't have any proof. You have no proof. You have emotional reactions to what you think is going to happen. You have fear, but you can't give me any concrete evidence that if you tried, that it would go terribly. You literally couldn't tell me a single thing. Maybe past experience still doesn't count for anything. It's all just fear. And again, you'll fear doesn't know anything more than you do because it comes from you. And you don't know anything right now. You don't know what's going to happen. That's why you're here in the first
这就是你想要的。它一清二楚。现在，告诉我为什么所有的步骤都不会奏效。告诉我为什么会这样。告诉我为什么你坚信事情不会如你所愿。你没有任何证据。你没有任何证据。你对你认为会发生的事情只有情绪反应。你有恐惧，但你无法给我任何具体的证据证明如果你去尝试了就会糟透了。你简直说不出哪怕一件事。也许过去的经验仍然不算数。这一切都只是恐惧。再说一次，你的恐惧并不比你懂得更多，因为它来自于你。而你现在什么也不知道。你不知道会发生什么。这就是为什么你一开始会在这里……
place. That's why you're so afraid. You have to approach it as if it's all going to work out. And under these conditions, if that was the case, what's the first thing you do? What's the first step you'd have to take? What is baby step number one that you would have to do? Just focus on completing that. Baby steps literally can't hurt. That's why babies do them. Like, that's literally in the name. It's there there to feel, they are there to trust, they are there just to progress slowly. If you want to start a business, registering a business name can't hurt you, baby step. Start the Instagram page. That's not going to hurt you.
这就是为什么你如此害怕。你必须以一切都会顺利的心态去接近它。在这些条件下，如果是这样的话，你要做的第一件事是什么？你必须采取的第一步是什么？你要做的第一步小事是什么？只专注于完成它。微小的步骤实际上不会有什么坏处。这就是为什么婴儿会迈步。就像，这名字本身就说明了。它们的存在是为了去感受，它们的存在是为了去信任，它们的存在只是为了缓慢地前进。如果你想创业，注册一个企业名称不会伤害你，这是小步骤。建立Instagram主页。那不会伤害你。
It's a baby step. Researching the opportunity, even if you're not acting on it, is a baby step. It's not going to hurt you. If you want to move to a new city, looking at visas, you don't have to pay for them. Like, just starting to save for them, baby step, it's not going to hurt you. These are all steps, all things you gain from, you will continuously gain from regardless of if you go all the way through with it. You introduce change and you introduce the steps towards change on your terms this way. You microdose change.
这是一个小步骤。研究这个机会，即使你没有付诸行动，也是一个小步骤。它不会伤害你。如果你想搬到一个新城市，看看签证，你不必为它们付费。就像，只是开始为它们存钱，小步骤，它不会伤害你。这些都是步骤，都是你可以从中获益的事物，无论你是否最终坚持到底，你都会源源不断地从中受益。通过这种方式，你以自己的条件引入了改变以及迈向改变的步骤。你对改变进行了“微量给药”。
I think also our intolerance for uncertainty also becomes more manageable when it's named, when we're planning for it. This is something I always say when I'm overwhelmed by things shifting. in my life. I'm stressed by the process. I'm excited by the outcome. I'm scared by the process. I'm excited by the outcome. Two things can be true. Then you can go that final step deeper. I'm scared. I'm scared. Why? I'm scared of the process. I'm excited by the outcome. Why am I scared? What is the human insecurity this is secretly, unconsciously manipulating in me to make me feel like it's all going to go wrong. I'm scared if I move, I'm going to hate it, I'm going to feel trapped. What you're really scared of is losing control, not actually of moving. I'm scared I'll leave this
我还认为，当我们对不确定性的不耐烦感被命名、被规划时，它也会变得更易于管理。每当我的生活发生转变而感到不知所措时，我总是这么说。我对过程感到压力。我对结果感到兴奋。我对过程感到害怕。我对结果感到兴奋。两件事可以同时成立。然后你可以更深入地迈出最后一步。我很害怕。我很害怕。为什么？我害怕这个过程。我对结果感到兴奋。为什么我害怕？这是什么人类的不安全感在秘密地、无意识地操纵着我，让我觉得一切都会出错。我很害怕如果我搬家，我会讨厌它，我会觉得自己被困住了。你真正害怕的是失去控制，而不是搬家本身。我很害怕离开这个……
relationship. I'll never meet anybody else. You're not scared of leaving the relationship. You're scared of being lonely. But there's no, you don't have any proof that that's actually what's going to be, what it's going to be like. That is just your deep human personal fear. then you can reinforce again that maybe this isn't the case. Again, use that five by five method I mentioned before. What are five alternatives? And what are five ways that I'm going to be okay, even if I am lonely? Even if I do lose control.
……关系。我再也不会遇到任何人了。你并不是害怕离开这段关系。你害怕孤独。但是，你没有任何证据证明这实际上会是怎样的。那只是你内心深处的人性恐惧。然后你可以再次强化，也许事实并非如此。再次强调，使用我之前提到的5x5方法。五个替代方案是什么？即使我孤独，即使我真的失去了控制，我能安然度过的五种方式是什么？
I also want you to notice here that none of the advice shared, none of the advice that would be given to you by a therapist or a psychologist is wait until you're not scared anymore. Speaking really bluntly, it's not going to arrive. You're always going to be scared. It's hardwired into you. Your threat system is designed to warn you against uncertainty. Uncertainty is a promise of life. Change is always going to bring about that feeling. Your relationship and how you act towards uncertainty is what is going to determine what happens. Not your imaginary, fill in the blank, catastrophic perceptions of it.
我还想让你在这里注意到，分享的任何建议，治疗师或心理学家给你的任何建议，都不是“等到你不再害怕为止”。直言不讳地说，那个时刻不会到来。你总是会害怕的。这是刻在你的基因里的。你的威胁系统旨在针对不确定性发出警告。不确定性是生命的承诺。改变总是会带来这种感觉。你对待不确定性的态度和行为方式，才是决定将会发生什么的关键。而不是你对它那些虚构的、填空式的灾难性看法。
If you take, you know, nothing else from this episode, let it be this. You're allowed to be scared of change. It's really fucking scary. You're allowed to grieve what you might lose. You're allowed to not know exactly how it will play out. But that being said, you don't actually know. And you're also allowed to decide that the discomfort, the terror of never trying is way worse than taking a step.
如果你从这期节目中没有吸取别的，就记住这一点吧。你被允许对改变感到害怕。这他妈真的很可怕。你被允许为可能失去的东西感到悲伤。你被允许不知道它到底会如何发展。话虽如此，你其实并不知道。而且，你也被允许做出决定：永远不去尝试的不适和恐惧，比迈出一步要糟糕得多。
just because something is scary doesn't mean it's not the right move. In fact, sometimes that fear is a sign that it is. Your fear-based imaginations are not predictions. They are designed to be the most intense, scary thing that you can imagine so that you can be prepared for it. They don't know any more than you do. And if you say it's going to be all right, if you say I'm going to accept the change anyways, I'm going to be prepared, I'm going to face it head on. if you say it's going to be magnificent, it will be. The chances are so high that it will be the way that you anticipate it if you anticipate it
仅仅因为某件事很吓人，并不意味着它不是正确的举动。事实上，有时这种恐惧正是它是正确举动的信号。你基于恐惧的想象并不是预测。它们旨在成为你能想象到的最强烈、最可怕的事情，以便你能为此做好准备。它们并不比你了解得更多。如果你说一切都会好起来的，如果你说无论如何我都会接受改变，我会做好准备，我会迎难而上。如果你说它会是宏伟的，它就会是宏伟的。如果你以积极的眼光去预期它，它极有可能会像你预期那样……
in a positive light, that it's going to be incredible because you have embraced something that so many people don't and they live miserable lives anyways. At least you can say I gave it a go. At least you can say, I freaking tried rather than dealing with the what ifs. So thank you for listening if you have made it this far. I hope you enjoyed this episode. I hope you learned something. Thank you as always to our researcher Libby Colbert for her research contributions to this episode.
……会变得不可思议，因为你拥抱了许多人没有拥抱的东西，而他们无论如何都过着痛苦的生活。至少你可以说我尝试过了。至少你可以说，我他妈的去尝试了，而不是去对付那些“如果……会怎样”的假设。所以，如果你听到了这里，谢谢你的收听。希望你喜欢这期节目。希望你学到了东西。一如既往地感谢我们的研究员利比·科尔伯特（Libby Colbert）为本期节目做出的研究贡献。
Make sure you are following us on Instagram at That Psychology podcast. Make sure you are subscribed wherever you are watching. Our question of the day, if you have made it this far, thank you so much loyal listener. Our secret question is, what is a change that you're going to be? are secretly resisting right now, whether it's moving, whether it's starting a business, whether it's dating, leaving somebody, whatever it is, leave a comment down below. Until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon.
确保你在Instagram上关注我们：That Psychology podcast。确保你在收听的任何平台上订阅了我们。今天的每日问题，如果你听到了这里，非常感谢你这个忠实的听众。我们的秘密问题是：你现在内心深处正在秘密抵抗的改变是什么？无论是搬家、创业、约会、离开某人，还是其他什么，在下方留个评论吧。直到下次，保持安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Care Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
嘿，各位好吗？欢迎收听《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Care Games）。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在任何地方都不太安全去进行，但你正在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套或盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2%。这是当有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science. of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的自己。在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》，即TWA%。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。
I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts,
我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友。听女性朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts上……
or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
……或者你在哪里收听播客。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和说是个大时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。在每一集中，我们选择一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代一样。那是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。这是一个IHeart播客。有保证的人类。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。